hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
uh september 21st what's going on
how are ya how's things going with you
how's things in your world i am taping
this sunday afternoon the patriots have
not played yet but
i am going to uh i'm going to talk about
the pat's game after i watch it i just
need to
pick my battles here when i can record
this thing so i'm going to record most
of it and then i'll come back
on after hopefully a patriots victory
you know i mean you can only hope this
time of year
i watched some football today you know i
was joking with the buddy of mine
uh i was talking to him about the
[ __ ]
you know i was talking to him keith
robinson i was talking to him about you
know
thursday night football joe burrow how
about joe burrow and [ __ ] uh uh baker
mayfield
putting on a show out there that was a
great game fun game
joe burrow looks great i know they're
owen too but he looks like he can take a
hit
standing tall in the pocket making great
throws and i would love i was loved
watching uh baker mayfield they're
letting them roll out
guy throws on the run like a champ um
you know who the hell was i talking to
they were [ __ ] on baker mayfield and
it's just kind of like
dude you know at what point is it the
brown's fault
how many quarterbacks can go to the
browns and not be successful
before it's the browns are you always
going to blame
you know the quarterbacks i mean it's
literally
just like road kill of number one draft
picks
who everybody wanted and the browns pick
them and then in the end
the person who was the quarterback of
the browns their reputation suffers
rather than people looking at the
[ __ ] browns the browns have been
inept
all right since they came back in the
league as the new browns
you know didn't they have an 0 for 16
[ __ ] uh
uh 1 in 15 016 all of that [ __ ] so i i
don't blame those guys so
i was really enjoying that game it was
good seeing the browns
uh you know getting a victory and all
that [ __ ] it was great to see the
bengals i'm kind of like at this point
now that we're post tom brady i'm just
like all right
i'm in my golden years of watching
football
i mean it was kid new i'm on the other
side of it i really
am even if [ __ ] cam wins it this year
with bill belichick which would be
[ __ ]
amazing he's not gonna win six
you know by the time it takes him to win
six i don't know he i don't know how old
that guy would be
but like it's um know he put the [ __ ]
ac on man it's
[ __ ] hard his balls in here what's
going on what am i doing here
yeah by the time he [ __ ] wins six i
mean uh you know
i don't know if he has enough career
left it took if it took tom 20 years to
do it
so anyway i was just watching sort of uh
just a bunch of different games you know
i got the the the nfl package
you know when did you know one of those
[ __ ] i think i [ __ ] about this every
year the fact that the red zone
is is separate from the nfl package with
all the [ __ ] money you have to pay
direct tv
i mean it's just i mean i remember used
to be 100 something bucks 200 bucks now
it's like 300 something for the nfl
package
i think it's because everybody's a cord
cutter now and they go on the website
and watch it there i'm probably playing
way too much money uh but then like my
on directv the the [ __ ] red zone
channel is 69.99
so i was just like well [ __ ] i ain't
paying for that too
so anyway i uh i watched a little bit of
the uh
steelers versus the broncos a little
rams eagles a little [ __ ] i was
i was all over the place you know when
your team's not on you're just
surfing right so i was watching a little
bit of the
uh what the [ __ ] was it the
jacksonville tennessee game
i watched tom brady of course they look
great today
beating uh was it tannehill and the
[ __ ] panthers
i watched a lot of football while also
packing up getting ready to go back east
to do my shows
which i cannot wait to do when i was
trying to squeeze in some spots i had a
spot to do some extended time for as
long as i wanted i was very excited
and i went down there was outside of la
and i went down there and it was just
another world i
showed up the crowd was packed
no masks i swear to god i think i saw a
baby in the crowd
over in the corner a little kid and i
was just like but there was so much to
like
sort of process that i don't know if
that was sort of the ptsd of the whole
situation it was just like
i was like what the f what the [ __ ] did
i just take a time machine
back to january what the [ __ ] is going
on here so i walk in all the other
comics have masks on
and then the lovely lady who ran the
room who was nice as hell she was
bringing out free food she wasn't you
know
for the comics total great person
but wasn't wearing a mask so i was like
whoa oh hey you know because i literally
just got tested in the morning
because i got to make sure coming from a
uh this state which i think we finally
got taken off of the uh
[ __ ] list um i had to make sure i
got tested
and so i got tested i got the little
kids
so i just said to i said hey you know
where's your mask or whatever she goes
oh are you from l.a
i go i go no i'm from massachusetts
because i knew what she was getting at
she goes oh you came all the way from
massachusetts to do the show i said no
i live in l.a but you asked me where i
was from i go you guys just don't give a
[ __ ] out here huh
and they're like oh no you'll see it's
different out here it's like oh yeah
how does the virus the virus likes you
guys
and so she goes i'll put a mask on if
you want i go that would be great so she
puts on a mask
it's hilarious god bless her every time
she went to talk to me she would pull
the mask down below her chin like we
were in a sketch
and i was like i can hear you through
your mask
she just kept pulling it down she goes
no you don't understand we're out here
we're by the beach
we get a breeze out here and at that
point i was just like
they are literally just making [ __ ] up
at this point um
and but you know i'm not going to get no
arguments with people but i'm also
i'm not going to go out on stage and and
i'm not doing it so i just left i i
didn't do the show i wasn't advertised
so i didn't leave people hanging or
anything but it was just like um
i don't know i i don't understand it but
i'm not gonna argue with people and it's
their right to do that but this whole
[ __ ]
reason they're doing it is just because
it's so [ __ ] annoying and
inconvenient
and especially out here in california
when you're this close to the mexican
border and you know that there's like
parents and kids that have been
separated and put in cells
for whatever [ __ ] reason okay the
fact that you can't
you know when that's going on a two-hour
drive away but you can't you can't put
on a mask
without feeling uh like your freedoms
are being taken away it's just
it's it's really astounding uh
i don't know i learned a lot watching i
was like wow so these people
are just like you know they always make
the upper one percent like they're all
these selfish [ __ ] people and it's
just kind of like well you know sort of
uh
the lower 99 is kind of wired the same
way they just don't
they're not good at running a business i
guess
you know they can't start amazon but
they
they people sort of think or enough
people start the same way and i had to
get out of there because the thoughts
that i was thinking i actually started
thinking like well maybe the next virus
will be way more deadly and then people
who don't play
ball will just die
and then people who are consider then
you know you have those fantasies
and just to consider it people are left
and then of course in my fantasy i'm a
considerate person
because i'm the judge and the jury you
know i'm sure if you asked enough people
they'd say no he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he would die too so i don't know god
bless them
evidently people if you're near a beach
and you get a breeze
you know covert just gets so chill my
favorite thing too was uh you know you
got all these fires going on out here
another favor i got a lot of favorite
things in this i don't i just use that
expression it doesn't mean anything it's
not my favorite thing it's just
some i really i should be saying it's
something else that i noticed
was he's uh you know
we've got this giant fire right and
there's literally like show up and
there's this
on the beach these people have started a
huge bonfire
you know and then that's just the kind
of human behavior that used to really
make me upset and now it just
makes me i just sort of step back
contemplate my own mortality
of like what we are really not wired to
survive
um is this how we're wired is this how
we are
or is this because of you know the the
usual
scapegoats like computers and selfies
and social media
i don't think so because i saw a classic
picture from the spanish flu whatever
the [ __ ] it was
and it was saying you had to wear a mask
or you'd get arrested or something so
there's obviously people pushing back
against that
um maybe there's just claustrophobic
people out there i don't know
i have no [ __ ] idea but i'm done
arguing with people about it so that's
that's how they're doing it down there
and i respected it everybody looked like
they were having a good time and i was
just well enjoy
your masculist existence out here and i
just [ __ ] went back to the car and
drove home
[Laughter]
so um i don't know
what are you gonna do god bless the
scientists
that are gonna figure this thing out god
bless the firemen
that are fighting these never-ending
fires
all the doctors and nurses that are
treating people you know
just god bless all of them but people
who are not trying to help those people
out who are doing work to help all of us
out um
you know i don't know god you know god
bless you too
anyway plowing ahead so
i got good news and bad news the good
news is two out of three of my
rotator cuffs are good but my i just
[ __ ] up the one
that's behind your shoulder blade i was
getting uh
i was getting a covid test because i was
shooting something
and everybody's got to get tested like
every [ __ ] day so i went i've been
tested for the [ __ ] like [ __ ] 10
times
uh still not gotten used to that giant
q-tip
going up the nose i just squint my eyes
and just
sort of grind my teeth just another
second
or two and then they finally get through
it
um so anyway i
uh i went to back out and when i look
behind me in the parking lot this little
strip mall there was a guy
motorcycle rider trying to pick up his
motorcycle which
was laying on its side and then i saw
there was a porsche convertible just in
front of where the guy was
the direction he was going in so i get
out of the car
because the guy in the porsche
convertible is not
helping out at all
which i thought was hilarious and really
sort of
fit perfect with the car the sunglasses
the convertible la he's looking out the
back of the car
and this kid's trying to pick his bike
up so i got out not thinking how much a
motorcycle weighs
i was just thinking like oh i've done
that that sucks
and it's too heavy to pick up yourself
especially when it's sort of laying
a little downhill so without thinking i
went over there like i was still in my
20s to pick it up and then the next day
my uh
my arm was killing me and i don't know
what happened i i don't think he hit the
porsche because there was no
uh there was no mark on the guy's car
but he did not get out to help the kid
at all which i i think is [ __ ]
hilarious
and then my dumb ass goes out there and
i re [ __ ] injure my shoulder a little
bit um
fortunately he didn't mess up his but he
scraped it up a little bit but
everything seemed to work but i think uh
i just think he came in a little too hot
the guy stopped or backed out before he
realized that he slammed on the brakes
maybe got up on his front tire lost his
balance and then the [ __ ] thing went
over
i have no idea but uh shout out to that
guy
i know a comedy show you should be going
to well what the [ __ ] he didn't do
anything right maybe maybe he's innocent
i don't know why am i coming down on
that person i have no idea why do i do
this
i'm trying not to be judgey wedgie here
um
what else how about your celtics your
boston celtics
after having built up a sizable lead in
game
two only to watch miami come out and
just [ __ ]
with this ridiculous defense i know it
was a 2-3 zone i
they were playing so so well i started
to like really look which i never do
when i watch hoop
i really started to look at uh
the defensive formation they seem to
have two people up top three people down
the bottom
all i know is whoever had the ball in
the second half of game two had two guys
on him immediately it was incredible
um was it the triangle defense i don't
know [ __ ] about hoop i don't know
anybody's names but i'll tell you when i
watch that game
i'm bad with the names when black lives
matter passed it over to enough is
enough
and then they kicked it out to uh don't
even try it white boy i mean
it was just some of the greatest ball
move i'm sorry um
i don't know the name so i'm i'm they're
underneath the number
so that's where you got to try and find
it you know the white guy's got build
the wall written above his [ __ ]
number
uh but miami looked incredible when i
watched game two i was like wow man
we're still
a really young team because there's no
way miami's going to lose that
jimmy butler would not let them lose
that and whoever that [ __ ] guy is um
i think he has freedom on the back of
his jersey the guy who [ __ ] blocked
jason tatum at the end of the game that
[ __ ] that's the kind of
number two piece that gets you a
championship
uh blown away by how well coached and i
and the only thing i got out of it as a
celtics fan i'm like i know
jaylen brown jason tatum all our young
players are watching jimmy butler and
those guys
learning how to win and at the end of
the game evidently there was some
big argument in the celtics locker room
right that everybody's talking about
like it had anything to do with them i
look that's locker room [ __ ]
that's sacred you shouldn't be in there
but you know this is what happens when
you put broads on the sideline they
start sticking them i'm kidding
you know it was probably a couple of
guys but um
that was the only part of game three
that i didn't like that they were saying
that there was this big argument
and i i think so and so said this and i
think this person said that it's like
who gives a
[ __ ] they lost emotions were high
and they were yelling at each other
because they care because they want to
win
because they're not just there for the
check which is what all these [ __ ]
[ __ ] always try to say about pro
athletes they want to win
so um
anyway uh i like when that [ __ ] happens
and i like hearing about it from a
player
years later when they write a book you
know that's why i really enjoyed that
jordan
documentary because i loved hearing the
story from jordan after all of those
years hearing it from
sports writers some of them resentful
sports writers
jealous or whatever or just i don't know
what resentful
i don't know um but anyways that was
great
all i did was [ __ ] just watch sports
this weekend i worked out once
[ __ ] ice in my goddamn shoulder i saw
game one of the stanley cup
final um
where dallas just looked great man saw
that yesterday
uh really enjoying watching them their
first line there
tyler sagan the ex boston bruin jamie
ben and that other guy number 47
whatever we had that nice spinorama
[ __ ] pass
out to that man on defense who went top
shelf
i love that goal that was a beauty i
love when a defenseman comes down low
like that and it actually pays off
rather than the other team having a
[ __ ] two-on-one
very enjoyable for some reason i'm
rooting for dallas i don't know why i
think i don't know
i think i just over the years tampa has
just owned the bruins and i've i just
feel like uh it's hard for me to root
for them even though if they win i'll be
happy because i like them
because i like eiserman even though
eiserman's gone and he's with uh
detroit i still feel like he's got a big
hand in a lot of their success now i'm
gonna get
[ __ ] emails from tampa fans actually
he left and since then most of the major
pieces had been removed
um so i watched a little bit of that
i i did uh oh and then the the biggest
thing
the biggest thing in my life right now
other than my lovely wife and my family
is uh i finally got enough time
flying the helicopter that i actually
sold on thursday and friday
the first time since april of like 2018
i was looking at my logbook
and i was kind of funny like i knew i
was soloing friday but thursday i
thought i was with my instructor so i
went out there and i
you know i preflighted it left tank top
off did all the [ __ ] i was supposed to
do and then i'm texting him where are
you buddy and he's like uh i
you know he's a musician too he's like i
got a session i'm i'm working
because i thought today was just you i
was like all right i guess it's just me
so i didn't really have time to get
nervous so i was flying out of uh
burbank this time and uh
i wanted to fly out west you know
towards camarillo and that type of [ __ ]
and oxnard all the way out there go look
at the just
it's a beautiful flight you go by the
reagan library i know you liberals don't
like that [ __ ] but like
i'm liberal but i mean come on man when
they have air force one
in a [ __ ] library it's pretty [ __ ]
cool um
and anyway i i went out that way i was
wanted to go out that way so when you
fly out that way
once you start going west if you guys
are on a map right now you see just on
the other side of the 405
is van nuys airport and that
is a class delta and it's the busiest
class delta
in the united states what i heard all
right that's where a bunch of bigwig
you know producers directors actors
athletes
announcers for the games they all fly
private in and out of that [ __ ] thing
so there's a bunch of g5s
landing and and taking off so
you transition midfield so
before you take off and it's so quick
that you
have before you get there you the first
thing you do is you listen to the atis
this is for all you nerds out there
right you listen to the 80s you get the
information on the airport
all right but you know most importantly
where the winds are coming from and then
you know if there's any new obstacles
any restrictions or any of that type of
[ __ ] right you listen to that [ __ ]
you get off of that you call the tower
before you call the tower you make sure
you have your next
radio frequency in standby so when
you're up there you're not [ __ ] with
the radio you can just
click the button to switch over so i did
all of that
you know called the tower they had me
hold on delta
i take off and i'm going over there i'm
like all right so you fly you do west
tracks you go along the railroad tracks
then when you get to the old gm
plant that's where you make your call so
i make my call and of course
every [ __ ] time they answer they
don't answer
so i'm flying and i'm flying i can't
bust their airspace or i get
major [ __ ] trouble
so i call them again how do you read
nothing so i'm like hey you got to be
[ __ ] kidding me so i just banged a
right turn
and i knew whiteman was 135. i got on
with them and i just
went up to five up new hall pass and
just got on the other side of the san
gabriel mountains i was like you know
i'll go over here
see what's up with this and let me just
[ __ ] regroup and figure out what i'm
gonna do and i'm just sort of laughing
going like this is like
of course this this it's just it's how
it is it's like you tape a [ __ ]
special on the way up to the special
everything's going great couldn't have a
[ __ ] care in the world and then you
[ __ ] show up that night the [ __ ]
air conditioning's busted
somebody with the stupidest [ __ ]
laugh ever
you know they're laughing etc like the
[ __ ] setups
something's gonna happen they stick my
parents in the front row even though i
told them not to
just all of that [ __ ] happens every
[ __ ] time
so um
i remember uh i just went up there and i
got up and i was on the other side of
the san gabriel mountains now they got
that
fire out there towards uh you know
the inland empire between there and uh
pasadena so i went out there and it was
really getting smokey and i was just
like well i don't want to be involved in
this now do
i so i um i ended up just uh
i just came back and i transitioned
whiteman and burbank down along the five
and that's when it got fun because i was
just like
i know how to do this i was totally
relaxed even with the [ __ ] with van
nuys
um you know i talked to my instructor he
goes well i would have gone into a
holding pattern i would have called
burbank to see what was going on they
also you could call them up 119.3 is
their main tower
now i know you just every flight you
learn something so when i came back down
the five
and then i just went out over glendale
then i was just having fun
and um everything it's so amazing like
all the stuff that your instructor tells
you it just
comes into your brain and pours out of
your mouth you're just talking to
yourself when you're up there
lights are out gauges are all green out
of the yellow carpet doesn't need to be
up
you know you start to keep your scan
going
be it 1300 feet here go up to 2200 there
but
you know route 2 134 positional report
the eagle rock
rose bowl and then i went out to the
rose bowl i did like a right orbit over
it because i had to
um it kind of bummed me out because uh
you know there's no
like a soccer field and [ __ ] you know
there's no football lines on or anything
i don't know if the pac-12 is gonna be
playing
i know the big ten is i haven't really
kept up on that [ __ ] then i went out all
the way transitioned el monte
down to 605 over the 105 up to 710 back
up to five
and then i went uh had to do it you know
past the observatory the hollywood sign
and then i went back into burbank
and then the next day i flew again and
did the flight that i wanted to do
and that time i got on with van nuys
transitioned it had no [ __ ] problem
and they
are really sticklers you're supposed to
transition at 1300 feet
planes are at 1800 feet and then there's
people landing and taking off underneath
you
you have to be right at that if you're a
little higher a little lower they're
going to get on you
and bust your chops because um
they can't have any jerk-offs in that
airspace so i've always gotten yelled at
when i've [ __ ] gone through there by
myself
and this time no problems whatsoever and
then i got out there
and um uh past santa
that uh what is it um santa susanna pass
santa paula all of that place out to
camarillo's absolutely beautiful came
back
and lined right up came right over the
hill
lined right up with satu koi there's a
there's a
there's a college prep school out there
that has a blue football field
and that's how i know like i'm where i'm
supposed to be
and i just get right on that and at
balboa you report after you've talked to
the tower came right in
and then as i came in there was a jet
landing so they told me to go 10 degrees
over there was two other helicopters
you're number two did
all of that [ __ ] set the [ __ ] down um
and i just i really just [ __ ]
i don't know i caught the bug again um
there's like a big thing i don't know
this is just with me as far as my
journey with this thing
there there's like i look back on my log
book is i only have
13 hours solo time like so much of my
time
is all just been with instructors and
[ __ ] so it's great i've done a bunch of
auto rotations and [ __ ] like that
but i don't have a lot of experience
flying solo
and it's only because of my work
schedule where every time i would get
enough time
confidence and and i was feeling one
with the machine
i'd you know have a tour i'd book some
acting work and then i come back and i'm
super cautious and i you know
i just always would work back up but it
just seemed like the gap between me
working
was never quite enough time for me to
solo so i was never able to push through
when i was really intimidated about
talking
like van nuys scared the [ __ ] out of me
you know
there's another one there's another one
down by long beach i'm not gonna say the
airport but the guy was just
just i don't every time i talk to him
he's like [ __ ] yelling at me and [ __ ]
um so now but now i feel like i finally
pushed through
and i could have done it again yesterday
and today and i would have had like the
best time
and um i think you know after this tour
when i come back i think what i'm gonna
do is i try to fly twice a week so i
keep my skill up i think now i'm gonna
start rather than twice with an
instructor it'll be once with an
instructor once solo
and it's just like the [ __ ] greatest
goddamn feeling i can't even tell you
it's so peaceful and relaxing and then
when i i
set it down it's like you're back in the
world again
you know you get on the road and people
are texting and swerving and [ __ ] you
get on the highway and these
[ __ ]
they swoop like you look in your
rearview mirror there's nobody there you
look again a second later
and there's this guy swooping in like a
[ __ ] fighter jet
to to like go around do not even be in
your lane go through your lane around
you on the right doing like 90 and then
zigzag back across like i'm telling you
these [ __ ] people in la
i mean they i don't know why they're
maniacs
they drive cars on the highway the way
those young kids ride motorcycles
on the highway other places like 20
miles an hour faster than all the other
traffic
i understand that with a motorcycle
to a point where some guys
you know when i was you know learning
how to ride and everything i was asking
them like what
what's up with it i said well there's a
philosophy it's
best to be the fastest person out there
so no one behind you can run you down
so it's like all right so i get that
aspect of it you know i used to play
space invaders i get you know
zagging and around down there but um
if you're going i don't know all it
takes is one [ __ ] idiot to do
something stupid
and you're going too fast to understand
it but i think there's there's a way
there's a sort of a happy meeting but
people do this [ __ ] and car i saw a guy
doing it uh when i was driving back from
that
the ill-fated uh gig down the beach i
saw a guy like a cadillac
escalade all the way left lane go
you know diagonally across like 80 miles
an hour high center of gravity in this
[ __ ] thing and then
go around like three people then i see
him cutting back you know escalade's got
those great [ __ ] vertical uh
headlights so i could watch the guy and
uh
i don't know it's a [ __ ] scary it's a
scary it's scary out there
boys and girls i will tell you that
because i know a bunch of you guys will
probably say well jesus christ bill what
are you doing that for that's really
dangerous and it's you know
there's an element there's obviously an
element of danger but you
the the level that you can reduce it now
in aviation
versus i feel like aviation each year
gets safer and safer where
being on the highway gets uh this is
just my own personal
opinion it just gets scarier and scarier
where there's like
like i saw this tesla parked on the side
of the [ __ ] road and it looked like
the guy
glued his laptop to the [ __ ]
dashboard just the screen
and uh i was like holy [ __ ] somebody's
gonna steal this guy's computer and i
realized it was like part of the car
and i was looking at that thing like it
there's got to be a way to shut that
[ __ ] thing off
you know you know those amazing
billboards that look like
you're in an imax movie and you're
driving by and you can't not look at
it um
i feel like those teslas like that's
like in the dashboard
[Laughter]
like you'd have to be a pirate with a
patch over one eye so you wouldn't look
at it you'd actually [ __ ]
try and pay attention to where the hell
you're going but uh those are incredible
cars
they are incredible cars hey you know i
just taped another episode
the bill bert podcast and i i kind of
did this funny thing where i bluffed
to my wife that i bought one of those
gmc rvs that i wanted
and she was surprisingly
sort of laughing going what the [ __ ] are
we gonna do but she wasn't mad and
that's why i love my wife to death
aside from the fact that she's gorgeous
she's hilarious
she's so [ __ ] cool
with the sh she allows she lets me she's
a pain in the ass like i you know i'm a
pain in the ass too but like
jesus bill can you just compliment her
um
yeah like she's really cool about
you know she'll give me [ __ ] bill where
are we gonna we don't have room for that
but if i really stay on her and just say
listen this is something i really want
and it's gonna make me happy she'll just
be like
okay
[Laughter]
so i was so surprised i told her i put a
bit in
on the thing and then the next day she
woke up
and she goes what about a new rv and i'm
looking at her like who
are you this is amazing and then i
finally told her i was like you know i
didn't buy that thing
i didn't put a bid in on it but i was
kind of like you know i actually talked
myself
out of it like i don't know what i'm
gonna do with a 26 foot [ __ ]
rv like what i'm i gotta stick that in
[ __ ] storage i gotta have somebody
start it up all the time
i mean i think it could pay for itself
in a couple of tours
um i'm just a sucker for that green man
the palm desert green i mean it's just
[ __ ] it's so goddamn
gorgeous and i just think they're the
best i think they're the best looking rv
they've ever made i love the new ones
and [ __ ] with the slide outs and all of
that but there's just something about
that thing
um and i was also thinking like do i
have to get a special license this
thing's 26 feet long i'd probably have
to get some
sort of third class whatever the [ __ ] it
is i don't even remember
um all right let me read a couple of um
let me read a couple of the uh what do
you call it the
the uh advertisement here for the week
oh look who it is
look who it is it's my bookie hey how
the [ __ ] you doing
uh i love mondays and sundays you know
why
two words nfl action
hey i'll tell you what i love mondays
and thursdays too especially after that
last thursday
uh game man they should do that they
should put the youngest quarterbacks
on thursday night because you know their
bodies aren't as
[ __ ] beat up as the old guys there um
anyway he says
the copy says i love sunday almost as
much as brady used to love
sundays in new england you [ __ ]
but now he's in tampa look at this i
like this i'm getting trolled by my own
advertisers
uh where the only thing he's got to be
excited about is that florida sunshine
uh i'll tell you what though my book
he's got this whole online betting thing
figured out you sign up you make a
deposit and they'll match you dollar for
dollar
so you've got some extra cash to play
with plus they got all kinds of cash
prizes
uh cash prize conte contest
and free bets uh tuned in late didn't
place your bet in time don't even sweat
it because they let you
they let you bet the game live so you
can analyze the game
and make your picks uh you gotta check
out the website because they got a
hundred thousand dollar super contest
that runs the entire nfl season
pick five games against the spread each
week
score the most points by the end of the
season and you'll walk away with 25
grand
but that's not it every four weeks the
player with the top scorer wins
five grand five g's everybody uh my
bookie is giving it away
if you trust your intuition you can make
a lot of money and have a lot of fun
who could turn down money and fun and
football come on
sign up with my bookie today and get
your deposit matched all the way up to a
thousand bucks it'll be the easiest
money you ever made in your life
all you got to do to to uh to the claim
all you got to do is claim is what it
should say the deposit bonus
oh two claim that's all you got to do
to claim not to the claim all you got to
do to claim the deposit bonus is to use
the promo code burp b-u-r-r
winning season is finally here and it's
only at my bookie how the [ __ ] you doing
huh
you feel good you need to eat gotta love
italians huh
um is that your idea of italians yeah
i've watched the sopranos
stamps.com everybody yeah they're
gambling and they uh they make the best
food on the planet stamps.com everybody
as we slowly adjust to the new normal
some of us are not adjusting to the new
normal some of us are just living the
life like it never happened
we still need to be smart about how we
do business luckily
these stamps uh luckily there's
stamps.com to make things
easier thousands of small business
owners have discovered the benefits of
stamps.com in recent months
they've been able to keep their business
running and avoid the crowds at the post
office
all from their own computers with
stamps.com you can print postage on
demand and avoid going to the post
office and you'll save money
with discounted rates you can't even get
at the post office simply use your
computer
to print us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your mail is ready
just leave it for your mail carrier
schedule a pick up or drop it in the
mailbox it's that simple and like i said
with stamps.com you get great discounts
too five cents off every stamp and up to
52 sorry no that is 62 sorry
off you p usps and ups shipping rates
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money right now my
listeners get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in bur that's
stamps.com
enter burr okay and with that let's get
to some of the uh the reads here
andrew was letting me know that there's
uh there's some cons renewable energy
i got some conspiracy here on covid
all right retracting uh
last week you said you misspoke about
the trump military comment
i was wondering what advertiser made you
do that
no somebody wrote in who cares if he
didn't say
it he's an [ __ ] and probably would
have
oh jesus christ uh i thought you were
against doing the apology tour but now
you're okay with it when it's spawned by
gop supporting underwear
oh yeah oh let's let's go back here
there's a lot of controversy in this one
um i didn't apologize for a joke
yeah and i i never said that if i'm
wrong i won't apologize
i was talking about jokes look at you
look at you trying to make a ball of
strike over here
i'm saying if i went up and i told the
joke and i was joking around i was
[ __ ] around
and somebody [ __ ] gets offended by it
i mean that's that it's
well i mean you that's you have every
right to do that but if i apologize to
you
then that means that i meant the joke in
a malicious way which i didn't
now going back to the trump thing
i just repeated it without looking it up
and i meant it
so i apologize for doing that because i
don't want to put misinformation out
there
misinformation sir is way different
than telling a joke at a comedy club or
on a special on our late night talk show
um and by the way
you have lost all credibility when you
say
who cares if he didn't say it so the
truth doesn't matter to you
because you don't like that guy and
you're so
neck deep in this [ __ ] that you know
that that whatever the the [ __ ]
advertisers which ones
support which candidate so i would say
that you're not exactly an impartial
person i also don't think
that you are a rational person
that if you say who cares if you didn't
say it
he's an [ __ ] and probably would have
i mean that you just summed up the the
case on a lot of
uh you know that's that's like how they
try a case on twitter
and that's something i don't want to be
a part of okay agree to disagree
um on that one wow
wow i thought you were against doing the
apology did i do the apology tour i
didn't think i did that
but now you're okay with it when it's
spawned by the gop supporting underwear
people you guys really need to stop
[ __ ] watching the news and you got to
get off social media
i'm telling you like listen to that
listen how that's [ __ ] work
who cares if he didn't say you literally
sound like that evil guy in in [ __ ]
robocop
who cares if it didn't work
um jesus [ __ ] christ
that's why that's why i was really
measured when i was talking about that
show down there i i still respect those
people i just don't agree with them
but the woman who's running the club was
was a sweetheart and brought out free
food so i like she
is a great person i just don't agree
with her
her seabreeze theory
agree to disagree and someday when the
uh
covet [ __ ] is over i will go gladly go
back down there
and [ __ ] do a show all right all
right
oh wait billy beanhead burr is what the
guy called me all right
oh this is the next one sorry conspiracy
billy bean head burr i don't mind being
head that makes it sound like it's a
normal sized head
uh as of right now i feel covid was
deliberate
yeah well i mean i think a lot of people
are a little frustrated so
you're gonna go crazy uh real but not
nearly as bad as they make it out to be
with covid new restrictions uh with
covid new restrictions are being placed
on us
and who where they're going
with and did you want to say
who knows where they're going with it
i love how you guys are just as dumb as
me um so we don't
focus on the fact that our
liberties are being taken away they
distract us with a troll
president floyd
etc
um okay so you think
george floyd you're not saying george
floyd didn't happen you're saying that
focusing on that was a distraction
for them using covid to take away and
put new restrictions on us
and you're saying that president trump
is just
a troll uh okay all right now number two
number two
bill where are you at conspiracy wise
with this i personally have been wearing
a mask
and always moderately concerned but
lately i'm finding lots of holes in
everything i hear
no information is true for more than two
weeks the false positive reports are
really what
have me thinking it could be not as bad
as they say
can you talk about can you talk how this
could the case could be the case
all right well these are all your
theories all right uh
right now i feel covid was deliberate no
i don't think it was deliberate because
it's
it's like people have lost a ton of
money on all levels
it's [ __ ] with everybody um
and if it was deliberate then it would
literally be a
worldwide conspiracy and for the first
time ever
leaders from every country all got on
the same page and said yeah
let's go with this so i can't agree with
that aspect of it i respect that this is
what you feel though uh
but not nearly as not real but not
nearly as bad as they make it out to be
um i think governments have a
responsibility
to protect their citizens okay and
just because it's not nearly as bad as
they
thought it was for people who are
healthy
um that doesn't mean that people with
asthma weakened immune systems
and and old people should all die
unless you're talking global warming and
we need to thin the herd that's a
completely different
conversation he said with covert there's
new restrictions are being placed on us
i mean yeah but they all seem
covered related i don't really see like
okay
uh well you know you got to wear a mask
and you know you can you can no longer
own a gun like i don't i just don't see
that
happening um and who where they're going
with it so we don't focus on the fact
our liberties are being taken away they
distract us
with the troll president floyd no i
honestly think donald trump
and bernie sanders are a reaction to
uh the banking scandal and none of those
guys went to jail and so many people own
homes
and they they lost money lost to home my
last you know
i lost money on a house um
you know those bankers [ __ ] all of us
and i think and i was in the same
headspace i wanted
somebody to bring change and that's what
donald trump was saying he was going to
bring
and hillary was just a company man and
i've said this before i really think
that bernie sanders
was the left's trump as far as like this
was this guy's a rebel now i know a lot
of people don't like trump but the guy
is a [ __ ] rebel
he is um and he made all these promises
that he was gonna drain the swamp and
all of this type of [ __ ] and everything
i mean just stuff that one man cannot
[ __ ] do
one person it's not a movie one guy's
not gonna go in there
and fix it you just can't do that um
uh where are you conspiracy wise with
this um i'm not saying that now that
it's come out that there's not a couple
of
there's not some dirty laundry that
they're gonna try to bury underneath it
like i was worried that they're gonna
collapse the dollar and say that the
reason why it collapsed was because of
the covid thing
rather than because of years and years
of their mismanagement of funds
their greed getting off the gold
standard and all of that [ __ ]
uh that's that's kind of where i stand
with that but i think the world is round
i think covet is real
i think trump got elected because of the
bankers in 2008
and um and the democrats
not having the right you know they they
what
it wasn't like a boxing match it wasn't
a good match-up hillary could have won a
different year
um or whatever i mean and hillary would
have been
[ __ ] horrific for a lot of reasons as
far as like
uh with bankers oil companies war and
all of that which i think a lot of
people wanted to get away
uh wanted to get away from um but now of
course looking back
um i just how overtly racist
and unempathetic our leader is right now
i just can't i just
that's just something i i just can't
[ __ ] sign off on
and it's funny i you know i got friends
who are trump show me example where the
guy's racist i just want to be like
do you really think that 35 to 40
million african americans
somehow are getting their own life
experience with this guy
wrong and you as a white person somehow
know
their experience better than they do
i don't know but whatever i'm i'm done
arguing with those people and you know
god bless everybody and if he gets
reelected i hope uh
he's like the grinch and he grows a
little more of a heart on certain areas
if he doesn't i hope this [ __ ]
straw-headed
[ __ ] scarecrow that they got me on
the democrat side to [ __ ] vote for i
hope i hope
he can live long enough to do something
i don't know but right now i'm rooting
for firefighters
scientists small businesses
and just regular people i hope you're
all help happy and healthy and i hope
you can pay your bills that's all i'm
rooting for i'm done
with all of this other [ __ ] all right
renewable energy
hey billy blubber button
i don't know why i uh that why i got
that but okay
uh i was listening to your mmp for
september 14th
someone from california wrote into
crying you was using renewable to power
the grid
saying that it it has shortfalls in the
stability of its power generation
uh parentheses i can't always see the
sun i think was the argument it was a
little more and
deeper than that um i have been an
engineer in the u.s
oil and gas industry i cannot believe
some of the brainiacs that listen to
this podcast it must be like you know
how my wife watches real housewives just
to shut her brain off i think
smart people might tune into this thing
they definitely don't listen to it
for the information
so anyway i have been an engineer
in the u.s and gas industry i have also
worked for a renewable energy think tank
i have seen both sides of the aisle and
wanted to write you in response to that
guy's
letter because he sounds like a lot of
people i work with in oil and gas
if he's if he's representatives of some
of your listeners
then maybe i can do some good here by
straightening
some things out okay here we go i like
this
point counterpoint uh there are a few
common arguments that
get rolled out as anti-renewable energy
sources
and so i'll deal with these briefly in
turn yeah i mean i'm of the conspiracy
belief that
um the current uh
uh i don't know what the resources that
we use for energy and power
you you're d you're [ __ ] with blue
blood money
and to try to get those people to change
and like i said the only way to do it is
you have to give them the sun
just shut off the derrick shut off the
wells shut all of this [ __ ] off
you know we're all gonna go solar you
can wait no you can keep [ __ ] selling
the oil and all of that [ __ ] and you
own the sun your family owns the sun
okay and when that thing burns out we're
all gonna be dead so you guys are going
to be good for the rest of your [ __ ]
life it's
the only way to get them out off of what
they're holding on to
that's that's my my my philosophy here
and then and they've they've bought all
the politicians and all of that [ __ ]
all right renewable energy sources are
unreliable
because sometimes it isn't sunny or
windy
uh so there are these things called
batteries
and the oh god he's going to he's going
to be talking down to this
us i love it so there are these things
called batteries and they store energy
the issue with bernie renewable up to
about five to ten years ago
was that batteries couldn't be built at
cost to store energy
on that scale however this is not the
case anymore it is now standard to build
a large battery farm with the new with
a renewable project the battery is able
to store and release energy to the grid
as required uh these are
already in use in the us australia the
other fire country
and many countries in europe as battery
technology improves
this actually makes electrical grids
more versatile and capable of charging
to meet the demands in real time
some countries in less sunny climates
such as germany iceland
wales and denmark are close closing in
on being entirely dependent on renewable
energy sources
to power their national grids how
exciting is that
they are not experiencing constant
blackouts
that's amazing i saw a youtube
advertisement for these these tesla
solar panels and i was thinking like if
i can stick those on the side of my
house why can't i stick them on the side
of a 76 gmc rv
just [ __ ] set the cross-country
record
three drivers we do it in 24 hours
because we never had to stop
uh number two renewables don't support
as many jobs
as fossil fuel energy does uh this
wasn't mentioned but it is a common
argument and one i have a lot of
sympathy for
coal coal and oil and gas are high are
huge industry
that employ hundreds of thousands of
people worldwide there's another reason
why
it's difficult to switch so we have to
do this in a way
where these people that work for these
companies and busted their ass and moved
up the ladder
are not left out of pocket here
especially in parts of america they
support entire towns and communities
um it has been argued that renewables do
not and cannot produce the same number
of jobs as oil and gas
in fact this is false a peer review
start what just makes sense if you're
going to be powering a whole city
are they saying the technology is so
amazing that some jobs are going to get
taken away anyway a peer review study
from
found for every 10 million dollars of
investment oil
gas creates 27 full-time equivalent jobs
whilst renewables create 75.
you might not be getting 200 000 to
drive a truck anymore but you don't get
peanuts either renewables require
ongoing upkeeping and maintenance too
so these jobs are not one and done
in in nature uh number three nuclear is
the way this is not so
clear-cut either way but i fall on the
side of nuclear not being a good option
here are my reasons nuclear power plants
take decades to get fully operational
always come in way over budget look up
hinckley point c for example
um has associated extreme security
concern and has nuclear waste products
wait and it has nuclear power plants
wait
and has waste products where the only
option to get rid of them is
to dig a giant hole drop it in and cover
it with as much cement as you can
to get your hands on even then you can
still
[ __ ] it up the u.s just spent 19 billion
on the waste isolation pilot plant in
new mexico
but a single mislabeled container
contaminated the site
just a couple of years after opening the
cleanup took
three years in a cost of two billion
yeah the only thing about yet the thing
i don't like about nuclear waste is is
the waste
and i was thinking well then you build a
rocket and you shoot it out into space
i don't know what you do with it the
benefit of nuclear power is that it has
no
greenhouse gas emissions that's great
and can produce
large quantities of energy in a single
power plant
however for me the juice is absolutely
not worth the squeeze
uh anyway if you make it this far then
thanks for reading dude this has been
fascinating
um i hope i have convinced even one of
your listeners to at least go out and do
a bit more research for themselves
listening to your stupid rants provides
a brief highlight
at the start of the work week that's why
it listens uh keep it up and go [ __ ]
yourself yeah listen to my stupid rants
i love it there's a smart guy out there
listen to this dumb bald idiot before i
have to go in here and use three
quarters of my brain
um nfl
getting it done bill uh why do you think
the nfl
is the only league that was able to get
zero code bid cases out of thousands of
employees for two weeks straight
straight these guys aren't in a bubble
they travel i firmly believe
it's because of the old school attitude
that lives on in football
there is still a gridiron attitude and a
lot of old school coaches and owners
around
that don't take [ __ ] the nba is player
dominated
and even though there is drama in the
nfl it's not that [ __ ] [ __ ] in the nba
all right you know what i got out of
that this guy's an nba fan
well here's the thing nba players make
way more money
than most nfl players so i think the who
is
um go after them a little bit more maybe
that's what it is i don't know what it
is sir i have no idea i don't know if
those numbers are right i don't know
i have no idea i have no idea
all right buying land dear bill i'm a 21
year old from a big city on the west
coast my interest in economics and real
estate has
has me interested in buying a small plot
of land at 21. look at you
good for you the area in which i'm
looking is growing therefore it's not
entirely speculative
excuse me um i'd be using my life
savings and taking out a small loan
which i know i can pay monthly and have
paid off
i've ran the numbers my only question is
this being my first endeavor i'm a bit
nervous
is this the start of something that will
ruin me or the first step to something
bigger
how do you get over that with stand-up
oh you went from real estate to telling
jokes hang on a second i need a little
sip of water here
all right um okay
i would continue to look at land i don't
know [ __ ] about money
other than i don't try and blow it so
i'm concerned that you're going to be
you said i'd be using my life savings
does that mean your entire life savings
if you have to do that you're only 21
i'd save up a little bit longer
you always have to have you always have
to have what the [ __ ] money
and if we've learned anything in 2020
you need to have that money
because they'll help you out for a
little bit and then you're on your
[ __ ] own so
um you know all these people who live
like in these these uh not always people
but a lot of these people who live in
really rural areas
okay if they paid off their house and
they know how to hunt
and they have a well in their land like
they can survive a really really long
[ __ ] time
um there is something to be there needs
to be a respect
again between red states and blue states
like this whole [ __ ]
real housewife [ __ ] that we're involved
in is it's really stupid
uh but getting back to you um
i get nervous when i i do uh when i
invest in that type of stuff but i just
make sure that i gamble with something
that i can lose okay and if it's your
entire life savings maybe you want to
look for land somewhere different
maybe buy a little bit less maybe save
up a little bit longer
but you're act asking how do i get over
it i would equate it to um
the um soloing how do you get over with
you just make the decision that you're
doing it i made the decision this week
that i was ready
and i was gonna solo so and then it
ended up coming a day earlier and then i
got to do it twice
and the how great i felt
about myself and um
and i called up and and you know i thank
my instructor profusely
i still and i'm still in touch with all
of my instructors that i've had
throughout the years
i still talk to all of those guys
because i look at them like
they've taught me one of the greatest
skills
you could have as a person learn how to
fly it's flying it's unbelievable
and they taught me how to do it safely
and i had nothing but great instructors
that um you know taught me
how not to fly like an [ __ ] so how
you get over
stuff is you don't take more risk than
you're comfortable with
but you do take a risk and you just have
to say to yourself
i'm doing this okay so
if you want to invest in land just know
you're going to do this and but then on
the other side
you don't have to like jump in the deep
end with rocks in your pockets when you
do it
okay you know you can jump in the
shallow end you can still dunk your head
under the water in the shallow end but
you know you run out of air you can
stand up
look at that analogy you get in the deep
end you know it can get a little [ __ ]
crazy so
if you still want to do it now um and i
think your background in economics and
real estate that are two
really great backgrounds
um for you to be successful in the
future i think your head's in the right
place
i just i think you're nervous about this
for the right reason it's it's going to
be
taking too much of your savings and you
need a small loan
i i i would be more
cautious than that you know um
you got your whole [ __ ] life ahead of
you so i would i would
buy a smaller piece of land that you can
that you can handle you can make the
payments it's not gonna uh
you know it's not gonna crush you or
whatever and then you can learn
on that one and then when you pay that
thing off now you got something you know
you got some equity in that you can you
can use that
to get a loan to get something else and
then you'll be off and running and
you'll be talking you meet people
in the real estate business that's
another thing i would go to open mics
i would talk to comedians people at
different levels
of doing comedy and i would ask him
questions and i would just
soak it up so uh don't listen to me for
real estate
advice um but
definitely talk to people that know
uh know your business because i don't
know your business but uh good luck and
i'm proud of you with 21 that you're
already thinking like that it's very
mature
you're out ahead of the game and you're
going to live a great life all right
just marry a sweetheart and you you
you're golden
and um you know
there's really something to be said to
being that smart in your 20s i wish i
was all right
all right now with that i'm going to
take a break here and through the magic
of time travel i'm going to watch the
patriots game
and then i'll come back on hopefully
talking about a victory
all right so we [ __ ] lost
[Laughter]
um i got to tell you i was worried about
this game
i i didn't know much about seattle i
know over the years people lose players
and all that type of stuff
um but i always know that they're really
good and
um as much as we lost let's first let's
compliment seattle on a great win their
team
looks outstanding and uh russell wilson
i mean what can you say about the guy
i mean the guy can beat you so many
friggin ways
um i've really become more of a mature
fan
i just i just did not get frustrated i
usually get so frustrated
when my team is playing a quarterback
like that where you cover the receiver
and then
the guy still takes off and runs and
still gets the first down it used to
drive me up the wall
now i'm just trying to i don't know just
appreciate
you know a player like that because that
guy was
amazing and uh i thought that running
game
that 32 chris carson carlos hyde too i
made a couple of big runs but that
carson just ferocious runner and then
they're receiving that 16 was [ __ ]
killing us
lock it and metcalf had a big day
i mean i don't know a lot of touchdowns
uh
a lot of touchdowns uh what's his face
russell wilson threw for 28 yards had
five touchdown passes one interception
he actually threw for six down
six touchdown passes if you count the uh
the pick six
but um i know kind of a crazy game
i think we kind of maybe had more
offense i don't know i'm [ __ ] tired
cam newton threw for 397 yards one
touchdown one interception
this is the thing i was excited about
was cam newton was not running all over
the field he was standing tall in the
pocket his throws looked great
and um i was also really really excited
our receiving core harry had eight
catches
birds got six look at me with the stats
out here rex burkhead had six
julian edeman which opened it up for up
for edelman who had 179 yards
eight on eight catches um we just
couldn't get in the damn end zone
because the
[ __ ] defense was great for seattle
but i gotta tell you as a pats fan
as much as we you know we lost and
everything
we competitive we didn't quit and we
looked twice as good as we looked
against the dolphins i thought we looked
i didn't say it last week but i kind of
thought we looked mediocre which is
basically dog [ __ ]
and but i thought we only looked okay
so um i was very excited by that
considering
uh the buffalo bills where they got josh
allen out there threw for 300 yards the
first week and 400 the second week so
that we're definitely going to have some
competition this year
and uh but i got to tell you man i
thought we looked [ __ ] great
i really did our running games sucked
though i will say that
but our offensive line did a great job
protecting
um cam newton and i also thought you
know i just think seattle's defense was
[ __ ] incredible but it's only the
second week
and we got a couple you know andrews is
back and we got a couple new guys i
think on the offensive line so
you got bill belichick and now you got
son of bill belichick
rocking the mullet okay and and i just
think by the time we get to
uh crunch time in november and
everything i think that this team is
going to be
really competitive very excited and i
love i love the new uniforms i love that
red
how the reds popping out on the shoulder
pads other than that um
[ __ ] seattle they just look really
really great
russell wilson man it's [ __ ]
incredible they got so many [ __ ]
just great players on that team pete
carroll man
and whoever the hell scouts for that guy
just they always just have those guys
that are
uh i don't know seem a little faster a
little tougher they just like they
really get those next level guys so
kudos to them
there you go there's my patriots wrap up
um as much as we lost like i said
very happy um cam newton looks great it
looks great i think i think this is
going to be
we're going to you know this could have
been [ __ ] horrific
tom leaving and then to have this man
i'm i'm
very happy that's it all right go [ __ ]
yourselves and i'll check in on you on
thursday all right bye-bye